gravité du financement de cet accueil
grenier merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
chaque jour plus de 90 mille voyageurs
utilisent les trains express régionaux
en provence alpes côte d'azur
chaque jour notre région subit baisse de
fréquentation forte hausse des coûts
fraude élevé pénurie de conducteurs et
plus de 86 jours de grève depuis le
début de l'année ce qui nuit gravement
au quotidien des usagers
c'est plus d'un train sur 3 impacté
cette situation est inacceptable
le service des ter coûte cher très cher
aux habitants de la région
un million d'euros par jour malgré la
volonté politique de la majorité
régionale conduite par christian estrosi
et les efforts financiers réalisés la
sncf refuse de coopérer pour améliorer
de manière significative la qualité du
service rendu
alors même qu'elle surfacturent 36
millions d'euros supplémentaires pour
rien le modèle est à bout de souffle
nous devons renverser la table pour
offrir aux usagers de nouveaux
transports régionaux et un service
public digne de ce nom
comment expliquez-vous à nos concitoyens
que les régions de france subissent le
monopole de la sncf au mépris du
principe de libre administration des
collectivités locales ma question est
simple monsieur le premier ministre
combien de temps allez vous attendre
pour permettre aux régions de france
d'expérimenter l'ouverture à la
concurrence pour leurs ter
nous allons déposer une proposition de
loi en ce sens et nous espérons que vous
la soutiendrai il y a urgence à agir
pour remettre les transports régionaux
sur de bons rails
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur alain vidalies secrétaire
d'état chargé des transports de la mer
et de la pêche
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée sur la question des ter qui sont
de la responsabilité
hier des régions vous évoquer la
question de l'ouverture à la concurrence
et des annonces qui ont été faites par
notamment le président est ce aussi je
pense que dans une démarche républicaine
est responsable il vaut mieux il vaut
toujours mieux me semble-t-il se mettre
dans le cadre de la loi républicaine
plutôt que de faire des annonces dans ce
qu'elles correspondent à rien en matière
de droit positif
or en la matière en la matière
aujourd'hui le monopole est attribuée
par la loi et depuis très longtemps à la
sncf le quatrième paquet ferroviaire que
j'ai négocié prévoit que l'ouverture à
la concurrence se fera pour les trains
commerciaux à partir de 2020
c'est-à-dire les tgv
et puis pour les ter à partir de 2023
c'est pas la position unique mandat
france était la position de l'allemagne
qui a aussi un opérateur historique
c'était aussi la position de l'italie la
position de l'espagne
donc tous ces pays européens ont décidé
qu'ils auraient une ouverture à la
concurrence en 2023 pas une ouverture à
la concurrence automatique
chacun prendra sa responsabilité
politique la france a tenu à ce que
figure dans le texte
pour les autorités organisatrices en
l'occurrence les régions la possibilité
soit d'une attribution directe à
l'opérateur historique en l'occurrence
la sncf soit un appel à la concurrence
ce sera la liberté des collectivités
locales d'ici là que faire effectivement
d'ici là nous devons faire une
expérimentation pourquoi parce que
l'ouverture à la concurrence on a
l'expérience du fret
le fret est ouvert à la concurrence
depuis 2005
le résultat n'est pas extraordinaire
puisque la part du fret ferroviaire a
diminué de moitié par rapport à
l'ensemble des transports de
marchandises depuis cette époque là mais
nous sommes favorables à l'ouverture à
la concurrence
ouvrir à la concurrence il faut une loi
et contrairement à ce que sous semble
vouloir aux sangles goubard monsieur
estrosi nous allons le faire nous encore
ses relations avec les régions nous
discutons avec les régions aujourd'hui
avec l'association des régions pour
définir un périmètre et une proposition
à ses textes de loi la part